today what I wanted to go over was
actually just a game game I'm a fan of
you probably wouldn't have heard of them
his name is a grandmaster from Russia
Alexei I have he's an older guy now
around 45 he's the same age as some of
the some of the top players in the world
he grew up with them not quite as quite
as good but still really really good and
what I like about his chest and I used
it growing up was all his chest is
pretty much easy to understand he he
does all the little things right and he
almost always has nice-looking positions
even when he loses he he doesn't have
you know crazy stuff going on and really
bad pieces and this is this is just one
of his games that I thought was pretty
instructive for for exactly that
building on just one weakness attacking
just playing he's a positional player
positional so yeah yeah that's that is a
style and I thought a lot of his games
would be instructive and I picked one
that I liked so he's he's a really good
Grandmaster in his opponents also strong
Grandmaster it's a game from Russia a
few years ago I'll go through the
opening pretty quickly because you guys
don't need to know most of most of it
I'll explain a little bit but the middle
game is where things become quite
instructive d4 Knight f6 c-46 this is
just the nimzo-indian a very common
opening bishop before Queen c2
it's a position where black goes for a
lead in development but why it has the
bishop pair so as you guys can see
there's two bishops two bishops for
white and but black is castled so you
know usually they say bishops are good
but at least black has development he's
he's Castle already
d5 Bishop g5 and this is actually just
the main line of Theory considered kind
of draw but what I like about the guy
playing white is he's very good in those
positions that are a little bit better
for one color or another so queen c4 b6
rook to d1 why it is really not
developing his King side but that's just
a theory so yeah did you have a question
or okay the Queen Queen a4 Queen d7 I'm
going through the opening fast as I said
so um this is when I'll kind of wanted
to start the Queen's got traded if we
count the material everything is equal
White has two bishops which doesn't mean
anything probably to you guys and to me
they're necessarily Bishop is on f1 but
the pawn structure is not exactly the
same if you guys you know we see doctors
there's you know a bit more of a center
for white he has a pond on the D file he
file and that file black doesn't have
his D pawn so white maybe has a little
bit of boy he has more pawns in the
center but black potentially has more
more Queen side pawns three to two but
okay it's just a normal position and you
know looking at it you wouldn't think
too much about it you just as black with
the Queen's off I mean you pretty much
want to just develop your rooks right
the way development works pawns then
pieces then you know heavier pieces like
rooks and queens the Queen's are off
here so black is black wants to develop
the rooks and he has a leading
development which usually you know you
use that to attack them before their
they get
pieces out both but miss drea have a
very very simple player he just likes to
play positions he knows Bishop f6
already so before black get started
because black maybe wanted to play you
know Rick theater moves like that he
does Bishop f6 G takes f six so now
Queens and two pieces have been traded
off so I mean you know it could be could
be some of you guys my things a little
bit boring but watch watch what he does
here how are these double pawns bad for
black not necessarily they can move
they're not blocking each other then
they're not pawn islands they did
they're covering they're covering quite
a few squares over here just the two
pawns beside each other so that's not
the main reason he did it probably just
it just makes things easier to to you if
you want to develop it's easier to trade
off some pieces then then your opponent
can attack you as much
he plays Knight f3 Knight 7 y 97 what
white wants to do who what are the open
files for for white the open file here
is the C file and for black it's the d
file maybe the G file they're both
they're both available so white the
black played knight c6 because he sees
in the future that maybe are highly
something maybe if you give way to move
you know something like h6 maybe after
move like rook c1 there's a bit of a
problem over here because then our
Knight is hanging our Knights being
attacked and our pawn on c7 will be
attacked if we move our knight now also
if we move our bishop back that's not
what black wanted because black played
is bishop on a6 on purpose he put in as
bishop on a6 so that whenever white
there was White's move whenever white
plays you know III he can take it and
okay you know he's playing black he
probably wanted to draw so you trade off
the pieces until there's no pieces
laughs so that's that's why he put his
bishop there
so he's not gonna he's not gonna you
know put his bishop back like that
when wait some time so 97 it's a you
know it's a multi-purpose move but now
now after work see one black could go
rook c8 so 97 III it does it anyways
block decider go Bishop e7 and not trade
and we're gonna get to the point where
it's it's quite instructive
you could go Bishop f1 and kill the
castling privileges but when the Queen's
are off the board a lot of times your
King is better in the center because in
the end game you know your King can
actually be useful as a piece and
everything like that so it's closer to
the action and it's not going to be as
dangerous Tiger King in the center when
there's no Queens on the board you can't
attack black can't attack too much in
this position if we just made a couple
moves look at the eight can you two
rooks see it it's just the position I
don't know how you guys would what judge
it I might say it's close to equal but a
little bit better for a white if
everything is the same then maybe these
pawns are a little bit worse if
everything is is equal but it's still
there you know so they both have two
rooks in the night and the same amount
of pawns but but he decides not to trade
and plays Bishop e7
this also looks pretty good I guess a
matter of preference although maybe I
would have traded on f1 just to keep
things simpler after Bishop d7 this
should be two so there's literally no
move none of whites pieces are an
aggressive square nothing is nothing is
serious yet and it doesn't look like why
it's actually even trying to win that
first glance it just looks like you know
is why you know you want a castle and
and then and then play the game but you
know he's he's just doing the normal
stuff you do in chess his pawns are all
on safe squares he has no weaknesses
he's developing his pieces as well and
he wants to probably castle next move
and then he can bring the the other rook
into the game black now probably wants
to do the same thing guys right after
you have your pieces of felt he probably
wants to bring the rooks some so at
least to probably do it or see it if you
have another suggestion of where the
rooks go feel free to ask question but I
think that's kind of what's going on
here but yeah you could and you could
have traded so this should be seven
there should be 2 rook FC 8 when when
when I when I look up see it is a bit of
a wall it's always hard sometimes to
figure out what works to develop and
yeah but one thing to keep in mind
though is III instead of you for that's
one move you know you for is there's a
lot more aggressive in law riskier a lot
riskier so it would have been different
it would've been different now after
Bishop d7 he's attacking the pawn so why
would had to do Bishop d3 but I mean
it's the style of the guy playing Wyatt
to not really play you for if he doesn't
have to especially maybe it's a small
thing but noticeable right now you know
we have LightSquared bishop s' so it's
logical he's putting his pawns on dark
squares so then your bishop is better
you want your pawns usually on the other
color compared to your bishop so that
your Bishop has has the squares that
complements each other to have the pawns
on dark squares and have the light
square bishop so that you know that's
maybe it maybe one positional idea
behind that to always consider you don't
want to have all the pawns on the same
color as your bishop because then your
bishop is usually getting blocked
blocked in by your own pawns because you
can't move through the pawns
so anyways Bishop d7 there should be two
rook F see it
why recap see it that's a very
interesting move I think you wanted to
play c5
if black wasn't to do anything as I said
white is just going to castle and then
bring us and his his his rooks into the
game you know in a bit of a better way
the rook on d1 is fine but this is the
open file for for Wyatt so he's not
really on the right open file but he has
to develop first so Rick I've said and
the other rook was also possible but
maybe maybe black wanted to do do do
something else with the rook on it so he
chose Rick fc8 and castles King f8
bringing the King closer to the pieces
rook D 2 c1 and yeah he's he's admitting
the rook is not good on that Square and
spending a full move just a little bit 1
square to the left but that is where
we're black see fellas and and if black
never plays if black never plays c5 ha
what's the rook doing on d1 it's not an
open file it's not an open file so as
long as black never gives turns out into
an open file which is a move like c5
that gives white the open file and then
the rook is you know not not ideally
placed so Dre F I mean your knight is
developed as white your bishop is
developed next thing to do is to develop
the rooks or push the pawns but you know
first first the pawns don't really have
some really good square to go to so rook
rook d c1 keep it simple take the open
files when they're available c5 he
doesn't now
if black didn't go c5 how do you put
your rooks yeah yeah rook F rook F to d1
if it was if white got another move
probably probably shift this work over
what's what's the what's the other
option with the rooks there's there's
that we can move the rooks to c1 and d1
like right here and there's one one
other thing we can do is on an open file
you have a few it's an open file you can
double rooks on an open file to you guys
know about that like how it's putting
two rooks on the same file so
potentially potentially you know some
sort of rook C to recap see when putting
two rooks on the file I'm putting a lot
of pressure on c5 sorry on c7 but still
the position is around equals so there's
nothing special going on c5 and now this
is finally where things get a little bit
dynamic if this is considered dynamic
you know the Queen's are off and
everything
c5 black black decides to gain a little
bit of space you don't want to keep you
know he's keeping this bottom of the
seventh rank you finally decides to get
some space with c5 but now after D takes
e5 B takes e5 what do we call the pawn
on c5 it's called a pawn island isolate
apart like an isolated pawn it doesn't
have any pawns protected it's considered
a bit more of a weakness yeah because
it's much easier to send the pawn with
with other pawns then then using the
piece to do it if we don't have to so
that's that's considered a weakness and
they also say normally you know you need
to have a couple of weaknesses to win a
chess game but okay at least finally now
something's happened a little bit
there's a weakness on c5 black block did
it voluntarily what's the benefit what
what did he gain well he actually gained
that he has another open file now now
the beef
I was gonna be open I think that was his
idea so he did something a bit risky
because now White has a really as a
target on c5 but on the flip side now it
makes sense why he kept his rook here
because he's gonna move his rook there
and put some pressure on b2 for you know
for every pawn exchange usually another
file gets opened up and another option
that that you can do but now now now
it's a bit of a different stage of the
game once once there's a weakness like
this you can play around that so 92 92
is the first move that that I like it's
part of this plan so now now if we did
want to do what I was saying before
let's say you put you played rook b8 y
rook ABA it has to do with is there a
what he plays rook e8 yes can we do
Knight B 3 right now there's 93 is still
threat yeah yeah Knight b3 it's a bit of
a tricky move but yeah they can move
anywhere for example something like
Bishop d2 discovered a bit of a
discovered attack hitting our rook kingi
to the knight is hanging and they win a
pawn here so it's a bit of a tricky move
but he saw that move you know he wasn't
think White's expecting to win upon just
yet usually you have to fight for it so
rook ABA
now so he defends against Knight b3 and
now now you guys probably can guess what
the next move is because okay we're not
gonna win the pawn right away we're
gonna have to make some good moves
but our piece of the red squares he's
not gonna just a lot blacks not gonna
gonna give it up easily so what's what's
what what does white do now just think
of small simple effective effective
moves we still have to finish
developments here okay so what you said
before right yeah now now it really just
guys rook c2 it's a multi-purpose move
what does it do it maybe defends in the
future against anything here that this
work can do but it also gives space for
another rook to come in and and look you
know it's a simplest one
you know he's you're not trying
something special and playing Rick a for
being fancy with rookie for rooks III
those are both not as good you know R
okay for others tactics rooks III maybe
the knight hits it well you know rook
see to allowing rooks e1 putting
pressure I mean the nice thing about
White's position and that's really a
trademark of a lot of this games like
there's no weaknesses for white black
black can't really attack white and
sometimes the whole game can be defined
or the whole game is about just one
weakness black doesn't have anything
else to do so you know this is a typical
type of position where you know one side
is kind of torturing the other side
there's nothing there's no targets for
for white for black to attack all white
sponsor or our place far away from from
black and it makes it really hard so you
know why it's controlling the game here
which is which is fairly normal from the
opening but still it's still it's still
a normal position it's a little bit
better for white but not winning or
anything like that the game still has a
long way to go
Brooksie - that's a good move and and
those type of moves are gonna be a while
you guys should look for later in the
game I'm be asking what's the move now
or whatever and and look for those small
little baby moves that don't look
spectacular but they have a little bit
of a threat without weaknesses so now f5
was played at five
control-z for a little bit more and now
this move surprised me a little bit
rook FD one I was a little bit surprised
when I saw it
because the most natural move could
definitely be rook F c1 which is
consistent with with what we're saying
about putting some more pressure here
rook FC one is a good move but then we
but actually there was a little bit of
an idea behind blacks move after look
something like recap c1 maybe black was
considering me like a ship d5 and the
whole point is we can't we can't trade
everything off on c5 because b2 is
hanging b2 is hanging but anyway she
goes rook d1 first if there was a way
for blacks to get rid of the pawn on c5
you probably do it but c4 is not
possible and and yeah so just just just
making a move that might be useful in
the future you know maybe maybe Wyatt
wants to play 9 c4 and use the D file
the D file now is at least open compared
to earlier Bishop c6 what specifically
what is bishop c6 threatening I'll say
his opponent who was playing black is a
quite a tricky player he's relying on
tactics and things like that yes part of
G - he might be a he threatening the
pawn on g2 he's attacking it but black I
mean white has a king defending it so
you need you need a bit more than it why
did he specifically play Bishop to c6
there was something specific about it
actually I'll go to you is that it a
question is that a question
why can't white take the pawn on c5 yeah
well okay that's that's something we'll
look at but why to the black play Bishop
c6 is there a threat there
you can move this bishop to a four
that's one thing and you can also just
take the pawn those are both good as I
one thing I don't want you guys doing we
don't want to trade pawns we don't want
to trade our weakness or we don't want
to trade off their weakness for just
upon we want to use that in tomorrow so
all the moves can be a good almost all
the moves are okay just
we don't want I don't want to trade the
pawns though that's one thing yes b3
there keep it keep it very simple b3
it's protected by the knight on D to it
now the rook on c2 doesn't need to
defend it your black plays Bishop d5 now
this is also a little bit of a critical
point this is a bit of a critical point
and hopefully you guys can can take this
home with you a bit the idea here white
is trying to play for a win in my
opinion black is the only one with a
weakness after b3 it's a little bit more
balanced the pawn on b3 is a bit weaker
now every time you push up on it usually
becomes a little bit weaker it's a bit
for it's a bit farther away for most of
your pieces and closer to black so
closer to the enemy that's usually the
case after b3 there are a few different
moves again we don't want to be trading
pawns so we're not gonna once again play
the very simple move like this and win
their pawn because the old one are upon
we don't want to be getting rid of that
part on c5 no there are a few different
moves beside to defend this pawn because
there is no rush that part on c5 is a
pawn it's an isolated pawn and it's not
going away anytime soon so first first
defend your stuff and then go for that
but then it comes the next question yes
you comment Bishop c4 I'm happy you
suggested that there's a Bishop c4 is a
move but there is a pretty common
principle in chess you know let's say
when you're when you're trying to play
for a win or trying to put more pressure
let's say we're not necessarily
attacking their King but we're talking
their position when you're attacking
their position you often want to keep
more pieces on the board you often don't
want to let them necessarily trade
pieces off
keep more pieces on the board and and
then you have more possibilities one
reason I can explain that should
hopefully make a bit of sense is that
pawn on c5 is a weakness but if if we
trade off all the pieces it's probably
okay for black one weakness is usually
enough to draw if we trade off a lot of
pieces what black will do is you'll
actually bring his King into the game so
usually usually you want to give you
don't want to necessarily trade off if
you're trying to attack or put pressure
because it makes it easier for the
opponent as well like for example if we
yeah like it's a possibility it's not
necessarily a bad move but we can avoid
trading pieces that'd be even better
because we want we want to keep keep
some pieces to put more pressure on on
c5 so there's a even nicer or easier
move here that's available but rook c3
just moving the rook up one Square
defending it because it said like we
don't want to trade pawns here in fact
we probably want to create pieces too
much where we're gonna let black make a
few annoying moves we're gonna defend
them and at some point white will
finally get the chance to to put
pressure on c5 but he's making all the
little moves first not taking any big
risk and and make it making simple moves
and and but we know we know like black
can't stop this is good this is going to
happen the pressure is gonna continue at
some point so Park plays 98 but I don't
think I don't think white cares too much
about what black is doing he still has
to finish putting his pieces on the best
squares you boys f3 so I have three
stops that idea and it makes him space
for his King just a little baby move but
I think is following the principle of
not allowing trades that have six King
f2
bring the king in waiting
well why waiting well he can play rook
fc-1 guys this is this is possible we're
done what that is that is an open file
but even when he goes rook F to c1 he's
not threatening to take on c5 like he
can win the pawn on c5 but this pawn on
b3 will be hanging in the very end if
you guys can see you know you guys can
see that rook dc1 and if I make any move
even if I move my rook away we don't
want to be trading off that weakness for
the pawn on b3 not yet not yet
because yeah not not yet maybe maybe
later if we win some more material but
it's it's not enough if we don't have to
so f3 some space for the king lots of
piece of in trade off the King as I said
usually wants to be in the center the
later the game goes it's time to bring
the King and get another piece into the
action it doesn't hurt
so if you guys have ideas about moves or
suggestions I'm happy to hear them
because there are multiple good moves in
positions which is which is nice as long
as you're not making the bad move there
are a lot of little small moves you can
probably make that that don't hurt the
position and that's something you know
when you don't know what to do and
things like that that's fine but I think
it's we just need to remember C 5 C 5 is
a bit of a weakness Knight d7 he's
moving around now he can't go to you for
so he just she's just shuffling around
but now the knight is defending c5 now
black is defending his knight sorry
defending his weakness with a pawn which
is better than defending weakness with a
rook now you can move his rook away from
the C file so you know he's trying and
maybe he's improved his position a
little bit so so now even if we were to
double the rooks things like that
we're not threatening to win the pawn
he plays h3 yh3 not such an easy move
so can you seven black could have
stopped this a little bit as I said when
you when you have when your weaknesses
you want to get rid of them if h5 and
black and white played g4 then okay
black would happily first take with H
and then you know trade everything off
he got rid of his weakness and white
didn't necessarily gain anything now he
has his own isolated pawn know if if H 3
H 5 this is a little bit advanced or the
whole idea was a bit hardest is he had
the idea of playing a 4 and E 4 take
sticks and you move the bishop anywhere
this pawn is hanging on h5 so he
actually had planned this probably well
in advance
either way black can't stop g4 from
happening there's this efore move if we
move this pawn if we move the bishop
away anyways take take and now this is
even worse guys this is one two three
four five five bad pawns not you know
all those are our pawn islands or
isolated pawns
now this pawn structure even though even
though why it's not up any material this
is actually probably a lost position
just based on that pawn structure alone
so black didn't play h5h three King u7
brings the King closer to the center g4
again g4 if black doesn't take white is
gonna take and mess up that pawn
structure and I mean you know sometimes
you try your best to let's say play like
white like this attack and you know win
whatever but at least he's making all
the moves to try to try to be black you
know so so g4 F takes G for h6g for now
can you guys now what has changed in the
position what can what did white
accomplished now
yes yeah rook say h1 rook to h1h files
open now and there's a isolated pawn h72
attack I mean he does not if you have
any other suggestions from white feel
free to let me know but all his moves
that least they're all all going for
those basic targets isolated pawns
there's nothing else he's trying to do
black has a good Bishop on d5 a good
rook on be it he's he's you know they're
both playing pretty good here but a
little bit the g4 move is very nice
because it's threatening to take on f5
and those are double those are those are
not good double pawns if you allow that
those are double isolated pawns so a
that's why he had to take you can't
really bring the King in to stop and
keep your pawn structure because of a
move like you know something like B 4 B
4 check would win the bishop so F takes
G for it takes G for rook e8 black
anticipates white is gonna play rook h1
rook h1 anyways why wreckage 1 anyways
even though black is protecting it what
what does what do we what did I say you
want to do is black get rid of
weaknesses if if I don't play rook h1
I'm actually just gonna make let's say
rook DC 1 what my black considered here
going with the theme of getting rid of
weaknesses if you have the weaknesses
and not alone and white doesn't know 1
allow black to get rid of weaknesses but
what would black might do what might he
do in this position try to get rid of
that over weakness
h7 is isolate upon guys h v h5 that
might be you know an idea and if this
was to happen well that's one less
weakness for for black and that's that's
a small accomplishment but it's but it's
something so
Rock h1 keep the pressure on these small
targets now h5 is impossible but the
game is all a game of cat and mouse
regarding the the weaknesses here so f5
a bit of an aggressive I don't think
it's quite a good movement I think I got
caught punished quite a bit but he took
instantly you know why did he take
instantly because he also could have
played g5 he took in Zoe
they were both possible I move like g5
maybe as well but five is now a pretty
weak bond itself I hope you guys can see
that five is a weak bond but White has
two to pawn islands whatever Black has
four black as much weaker pawns here and
it's important to note f5 f5 is on the
light square when you when you when you
determine a weakness and you have a
bishop on the board it's always nice to
think at the back of your head you know
is that pawn on the right square as my
bishop because if it's not then even if
it's a weakness you might not be able to
ever take it if you have a bishop if
your bishop can never if it's not on the
right color then it can't really do much
pressure so that's something to consider
an H 5 H 7 and f5 or both weaknesses
rook h4 wire cage for I think there's a
few decent moves here and and a lot of
them I would accept I mean work age six
if any but he wants to keep on the rook
on the H file wreckage for maybe as
ideas to rotate for as well but I
controls it can control both the end
your hand up yeah rook h4 h5 I think I
think you know what I think is one of
those games you know what black got
pretty uncomfortable of the position
because he you know he might have been
bored
he has no targets to attack you know
he's an aggressive player and and this
was difficult but h5 each time is not
it's not a bad move because and we
compare the rooks right now White's rook
is much better he's putting pressure but
he has a lot of space so h5 may be not
only the pond is still defended but
maybe at least he has more space for his
rocks he can double rooks yes and he did
before and now things get a little bit a
little bit interesting because I didn't
want people playing before for most most
of it and yeah if some of you guys have
to go it's okay game is done soon
b4 is not not consistent with keeping
keeping that weakness there but I think
what he realized was he has enough
weaknesses now before there was only
pretty much one weakness
now all black spawns or weak so he can
afford giving up one of them if he still
has the other three so for example after
b4 take take which is what happened
black was happy to take maybe this pawn
on a7 is is a target the rook has an
open file so he kept a lot of weaknesses
here so it wasn't a big deal I think
that was his thinking but if you only
had one weakness or two weaknesses I
think he wouldn't have allowed that you
don't want to get you don't want to
allow the trade there so so before f4
was possible
it takes C takes before it takes before
of course taking back with the pawn now
a7 can be targeted a couple of ways
rook age six so we're back sorry about
that
rook age six and now and now very nice
move Knight f1 as I said I think white
was happy that black had a bunch of
weaknesses besides c5 now so he was
happier didn't mind trading that off and
Knight f1 what's the idea of Knight up
one guys yes 93 93 will attack both of
those weak pawns and it's really nice
those pawns are all in the color of
white spaceship as well so he can
continue putting pieces there but the
whole time
there hasn't been any situation where
black had an opportunity to attack
quieter or you know change change the
game or use tactics because these pawns
are so so closely placed to White's
pieces they're protected no matter what
there's no way to to challenge them so
Bishop e6 93 is possible now but like
something like Knight f6 and it's still
you know sometimes winning one pawn is
enough so I black white is still maybe
going for a little bit more making some
more weaknesses or whatnot or whatever
but yeah you could have gone 93 here 93
would have been would have been okay
Knight f6 and try to push but first but
it works e7 but the point is already at
this stage this position is already a
lot better for white white is what is
almost winning as I said two weaknesses
is usually enough there are three
weaknesses here pawn on b4 might be a
little bit loose source but it's pretty
close to that that two weakness type of
goal we wanted so now what white needs
to do is he doesn't mind trading because
he's probably gonna win upon if that
happens those pawns are so weak but he's
he's looking for material now though the
pawns are all really really weak
Brooks e7 hitting a7 that rook is free
to do whatever it wants because this
rook is as I said really nicely placed
Rick c7 rookie it can't go a six only
way to defend the pawn B 5 B 5
another another good easy move to
understand it keeps keeps that pawn on
a7
you know fix the pawn can't go forward
can't move can't move now yeah because
one will just take it that the ship is
supporting it
King d8 why king D a while he wants to
he wants to kick the rook away so he his
rook isn't stuck on it the blacks works
away more passive than whites works on
top of the weaknesses we talked about so
King King d8 rook c6 what's rook c6
doing well this Bishop can move the rock
on h6 is hanging if that's the case but
ya know I'm pretty sure at this point
white smell blood and he's he's going
for for the kill here he's starting to
gain space he's starting to now he's now
he's gonna get these guys into the game
but first you know he got all his other
pieces set up first rook c8 at least
it's possible trade off getting a bit
desperate here rook t4 a pretty nice
move why rook t4 I said as you know
black men want to trade off pieces but
he can't do that
Brooks Brooks e6 b c6 so so now once
again it's not possible at this point I
was a little curious maybe y h4 wasn't
played or just some sort of waiting move
you know it's a weak pawn so why not
push it and try to get rid of it but
there was some tactics here going on and
this stuff you don't necessarily need to
need to know too much but it's not a
coincidence that in a very good position
tactics come it's not it's not a
coincidence queires you get the
advantage and the tactics work and
actually after a move like rook rook
d-46 the game would actually be over so
it came all of a sudden it sound like
White's been playing aggressive but all
he why it's already winning yes
rook rook b8 almost almost there guys
so he's black oh just moving around he
can't do anything Knight g3 now he's
bringing the pieces in rook p6 but all
of whites all black's pieces are pretty
much paralyzed
rook d6 rook d4 d6 9f5 was the threat
and they takes f5 the bishop couldn't
take that's why he played rugby 6 rook
DD 6 yeah yeah white could have taken
the pawn here the game ended very
quickly even though blacks really good
player Bishop c4 and that Bishop is
pretty much dead he had to he move the
bishop away rook on g6 is hanging but
after rook takes b68 takes b6 remember
it's not this doesn't work because this
rook is protecting that even though
maybe it was still good for white rook
p680 xp6
and this is probably the only time in
the game where he calculated deeply this
whole sequence rook takes d7 checking d7
Bishop takes f7 attacking the rook
moving away
Bishop h5 that was some sort of tactical
sequence we don't have to look too much
into that but it's two pieces for the
rook and that's supposed to be almost
winning in a lot of positions because
there's a pawn as well two pieces and a
pawn so now white gets an actual winning
position he converts it smoothly but
it's literally a type of game I don't
believe white had to calculate it for
most of it a lot of those moves were
very very positional very sound and
without much risk so I'll show how the
game ended but you know the whole theme
was either waiting for a weakness making
weakness but keeping that weakness there
playing
and not giving your opponent much
counterplay but he he didn't play any
special moves this game for the most
part so usually two pieces be with a
pond does beat a rook because the two
pieces can push the pawn and that's what
happened here
and I mean yeah black resigned but it's
cuz yeah the two pieces are the same
they keep the rook the rooks in line and
then the extra pawn is enough but that's
the way the game ended I thought it was
I thought its you know when I was when I
was you know younger I wasn't so good at
positional positional chess and studying
this guy's games helped me quite a bit
because I'm sure a few guys are pretty
good at tactics at spotting blunders and
things like that but sometimes it's
those little baby moves that those
little small details that that go pretty
far and I thought this was a nice game